let me briefly introduce why
bioinformatics for infectious diseases i
mean why do we need a special program
that is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases how do we
think about infectious diseases compared
to other types of diseases and
conditions and then i'll briefly
introduce you to some of the challenges
that are still being a hot topic in this
area of research and then i will pass it
on to the mentors on the program that
will speak about some of the technical
aspects including some of the case
studies that we will use throughout the
program so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a training program designed
to introduce students clinicians and
researchers to the role and the
applications of bioinformatics to the
study of pathogenic microorganisms and
their interaction with the host which
lead to and enable human disease
and our understanding of the
pathogenesis of these diseases can lead
to meaningful interventions
interventions like antiviral drug design
or maybe vaccine design we'll talk about
this in just a few more minutes
so in this webinar what we'll do is
we'll use some of the examples that are
case studies that we source from high
impact publications
and extract from their examples of
meaningful application of bioinformatics
methods of analysis to different types
of omics data including genomic data
transcriptomic data metadata genomic
data and others and so what i'll do in
my part of the presentation
is i will give you a glimpse of how some
of these different methods of analysis
are used and have been developed to be
applied to understand and intervene in
these kinds of diseases including some
of the additional challenges that are
still being researched and how we can
leverage the publicly available data
sets that are out there to be able to
ask these questions of
of
relevance and importance to what's
happening right around us
so the infection itself
what is it and why are we speaking about
infectious diseases as a whole category
of uh applications of bioinformatics so
infection is the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents their
multiplication and the reaction of host
tissues to the infectious agents and the
toxins that they produce
so an infectious disease is also known a
as a transmissible disease or
communicable disease and it is an
illness that results from the entry or
the actual infection and replication of
that pathogen
so the infections that are caused by
infectious agents called pathogens or
include viruses
as well as agents such as virus which
are not exactly viruses bacteria fungi
parasites
and then they are different from
non-infectious diseases which are also
recognized as chronic and can be caused
by such factors as the environment
nutrition lifestyle as well as genetic
inheritance so we typically think of
them as two separate categories but as
we will see today they actually have a
lot in common and one can be the result
of the other
so the replication of pathogens in the
host leads to major interference
starting from membrane disruption as in
the case with viruses and the release of
toxins as the case of many bacterial
pathogens maybe of these many of these
interferences include molecular
biological pathways that are designed to
fend off intruders and signal to
neighboring cells of danger
the pathogens can modulate these
pathways and cause long-term organ
damage such as lung tissue scarring due
to the immune hyperactivity so
understanding of these biological
mechanisms
the way that the entry happens the way
that the body responds the way that the
viral and bacterial pathogens can
take and modulate those are all the
subject of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases because most of this
information comes from data
so let's take a look at some example
publications
to see
how
this has been monitored and studied
using different types of omics data
so the first example i want to bring up
is the outbreak of ebola virus that
happened in the
2014-2016 outbreak in west africa and
led to almost real-time genomic
surveillance of this disease
as a result genomic technologies were
shown to be effective and useful in an
outbreak of an epidemic and led to
significant interventions like the
discovery of antiviral compounds and
design of vaccines and so as a result of
genomic surveillance better
understanding of the disease and
intervention was a meaningful success
that shows how valuable genomic data is
and therefore bioinformatics which
allows us to study this kind of genomic
data and find meaningful insights in
this data
another example that i have here is an
example from stars cove two so obviously
living in the pandemic the role of
genomic surveillance allows us to answer
key questions about where did the virus
emerge from how is it developing over
time and how can we anticipate future
directions for this viral replication
evolution in order to be more effective
at the types of interventions that we
can implement including the testing of
whether standard interventions that we
think are effective or advanced
interventions that we might not think
are effective at all could be applied in
a meaningful way to contain this
pandemic
another example that you can see here
is the genomic surveillance of
plasmodium falciparum which is malaria
that is endemic in some areas of africa
and
still to this day after millions of
deaths
has not been
addressed using new vaccine so to
understand this specific pathogen
genomic surveillance is being used also
to understand various factors that lead
to greater transmission
replication severity of disease and as a
result we can see how interventions are
being developed and tested that are
becoming more and more effective to
contain this disease
another interesting article that is
fairly recent is the increased
serological response against human
herpesvirus6a
which is associated with risk for
multiple sclerosis this idea has been
proposed back in the 1990s but only
recently have there been validated
studies that show that indeed there is a
statistically significant association
between human herpes virus and the
development for multiple sclerosis which
leads us to think about many other types
of diseases that we think are purely
neurological or perhaps genetic and
result of somatic mutations like cancer
but in fact are caused by different
types of infectious agents pathogens for
example here are the seven known viruses
that cause human cancers so an estimated
12 to 20 of cancers worldwide are
thought to be
resulting from tumor viruses
so we're not only speaking about in
diseases that can be monitored and
studied using omics data we're also
speaking about other diseases that we
haven't asked about what
caused through but those associations
are started to be
important to understand
so those were viruses what about
bacteria
bacteria are another pathogen some
bacteria could be pathogenic and
interestingly you can see this article
here that was uh from 31st of january in
2022
the staggering
toll of drug resistant bacteria which
talks about a global survey that shows
that in 2019 antimicrobial resistance
killed more people than hiv or aids or
malaria so not only do we see that
viruses parasites but also bacteria is a
major cause for global health
not only that we also see that
drug-resistant tuberculosis poses a
major risk to global health security and
we all hear about antimicrobial
resistance in hospitals of new superbugs
that are not even known how to be
treated so this area of research is not
only interesting is not only relevance
of the pandemic that we're living
through but it is also a major direction
for anyone who's interested to apply
bioinformatics skills and data analysis
skills to address major challenges that
we face today and will continuously face
in the future
one of the interesting things about the
different pathogens that we discussed is
that naturally our body already has a
response to many of these infectious
pathogens
hosts can fight infection using their
immune system the mammalian hosts react
to infections with an innate response
often involving inflammation followed by
an adaptive response vaccines are used
to train the immune system to identify
pathogens and store the necessary
epitopes for antibody production in the
long term immune memory
but due to a variety of factors such
immune responses can be insufficient on
their own
two main approaches that have
significantly reduced death from
infectious diseases in the past century
are the antibiotics antiviral drugs and
vaccines
in fact if we look at the timeline
we can see that the vaccines have been
discovered first but many other
ways to intervene have reduced
significantly the risk that infectious
pathogens
cause
or
pose so here you can see
from the 900s all the way to 2000s this
is the rate of infection which is a per
100 000 population per year
you can see here simple interventions
for example
a health departments establishment of
health departments or continuous
municipal use of chlorine in water in
the united states uh you can see the um
kind of how specific diseases that we
think maybe are you know well into the
past have actually not been so uh long
ago so this is the influenza the flu
pandemic that killed millions of people
uh plague uh that was uh
last observed here in the 1920s
the use of penicillin if you think of
penicillin as something that was
you know discovered long ago you can see
that actually that was in the 1940s so
not that long ago and the first vaccine
that was introduced in the 1950s
so all of this is recent history this is
the history that many of us have uh
our parents go through our grandparents
through we know that these things have
happened very recently and a lot of the
developments that we are using today are
based on these kinds of interventions
but
over the
since we see such tremendous decrease in
these kinds of pathogenic diseases one
might think that well we've mastered
the way to train our immune systems and
protect ourselves from these pathogens
but in fact we see that covid19 has
proved all of us wrong
here you can see
this is a comparison to different other
causes of death and covet 19 surpassed
all of them which shows clearly that we
have not mastered the art of interview
or understanding and being able to
effectively intervene with these uh
different pathogens however what does
give us some promise so bioinformatics i
think is one of those disciplines that
allows us to be to stay
you know somewhat optimistic about the
future of infectious disease research
and the reason i say that is because
with covet 19 what we have seen is the
continuous application of biotics and
data science to
practical interventions that are being
used in real time and are being used to
adapt a response quickly to this
dramatic threat that we now understand
much better and we know how to intervene
much better as well what is
bioinformatics bioinformatics is the
intersection of computer science biology
and statistics and what i mean by that
is that we are able to apply
algorithms and software rely on
databases of different types of data and
use these data science skills to be able
to analyze data but this data isn't
meaningful unless we understand the
biological context and so the biological
context the specifics of infectious
diseases the pathways the different
pathogens the biology of the interaction
between the host and the pathogen all of
those are a critical component for us to
be able to ask meaningful questions and
find answers that are significant and
relevant to the type of data now in the
middle of that our statistical and
machine learning or analytical skills
that we need
and those analytical skills primarily
are driven by our
new structure data and then ask
questions that are generalizable these
questions they're not only relevant to a
particular study they're relevant in
general to some biological phenomena
so
one of the important things in the
context of infectious diseases is that
particularly in this area there has been
a dramatic increase in the number of
data size uh data uh databases and data
types that are available for infectious
disease research so here you can see
this is a slide from maybe a few months
ago but you can see here that the rate
of discovery of viral genomes the way
that these databases have become
structured and accessible is increasing
dramatically and that means that we can
start asking meaningful questions about
all of these types of questions that we
might have that we just learned about in
a fairly easy and user-friendly way
and so the purpose of training in the
context of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is to start thinking how can i
ask an important question what kind of
examples can i follow and where can i
find data sets that provide me with
sufficient answers that i'm looking for
because even though so much has been
already done
not everything is clear in fact we know
that the diseases that are caused by
pathogens vary significantly between
individuals locations or even whole
populations
they happen at different speed at
different severity and the understanding
of how they happen is linked to a very
deep understanding of the immune
responses as well as the
evolution of these pathogens
and not only that we also are now
discovering that many of these viruses
and emerging pathogens are actually not
only
in uh individuals but they also are
in the environment they're all around us
they're in other animals and other
species and so we have to expand our
understanding of this molecular biology
to also be able to detect specific types
of
pathogens like viruses in other
environmental samples that we might not
have thought of yet and that leads us to
this major challenge of annotation and
curation of data to understand
relationships between strains species
and viola of different pathogens
and our ability to then understand their
function how do they function how do
they interact with the host
so in the context of this program one of
the key technologies that we're going to
be using and we're going to be talking
about a lot is next generation
sequencing
next generation sequencing could be used
in many different ways
it could be used to analyze individual
genomes like the covet 19 genome it
could be used to analyze meta genomes
where we have a collection of genomes in
a particular sample and we need to
understand diversity or maybe
relationships between these genomes
and also we need to understand the
different types of library preparation
techniques and steps to prepare the data
to make sure that we can answer specific
questions
now to be able to use this data we need
to understand the biology we need to
find the right kinds of data and then we
need to know a variety of techniques
that will make it easy for us
interpret and find meaningful
associations
and that includes understanding of viral
genomics and evolution or phylodynamics
how can we build phylogenetic trees and
monitor progression over time connecting
it with
temporal or maybe different types of
phenotypes that we have
understanding of transcriptomic data or
how to find differences in gene
expression and compare and contrast
different types of conditions or groups
of samples
variant calling where we can find
variance in specific positions of on the
genome and be able to interpret them
and analysis of
metagenomic data data that contains
thousands or even millions of different
microorganisms that need to be
categorized and
found relationships between them
the examples you i'm sure that you have
seen um you know in the news and
elsewhere but the examples that we will
use in this program
include uh
such epidemics like the ebola virus
which you can see right here
the understanding of
origins transmission replication
and development of continuous evolution
in this pandemic and how it affects our
bodies ability to respond to infection
and produce relevant immune responses
differentiating between specific
processes and stochastic processes
and then linking this understanding with
our ability to take a sample and monitor
the specific types of
clades and variants that are of concern
and ultimately being able to translate
this information
to report on our findings communicating
the results effectively with meaningful
annotation and
interpretation so to summarize what we
will do in this program is we will take
a look at different types of
omics data including genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data we
will learn to deal with these data sets
align them
find associations using different types
of processes interpret them using our
understanding of structure and function
of different genes and proteins and then
measure host responses to really
understand how does the host respond to
the different infections that are there
now data
from next generation sequencing is very
complex this is an alignment of one of
the first sequencing data sets from the
soros cov2
samples that were identified in china
and so as you can see here it's not
trivial to get from this kind of complex
information to some meaningful insights
and so what we will try to do is we will
try to break it down to understand the
principles
behind the data that we have
the analysis methods that help us to
perform some of the functionality
in a semi-automated way
link that with biological understanding
of the processes that drive
the observed variation that we have in
the data and then use analysis methods
that help us
link those into meaningful models behind
the process that we think is driving
this variation
now ultimately we will also talk about
ways to interpret such data not only
find specific variation that is
meaningful but then also use the
appropriate route for interpretation and
we will use the different examples to
link this kind of sequence variation to
actual interaction and function of
different proteins that anyone can do
independently once you find the relevant
meaningful differences in your data sets
now to speak about specific examples of
how this type of bioinformatics approach
can be used to study viruses bacteria
and different types of
pathogens i want to invite our mentors
that will be helping you work through
these different case studies apply these
different technical methods and find
meaningful insights from relevant
biomedical publications i want to
introduce you to our mentors
dr raghavendran
is going to be your research consultant
and mentor he's going to be helping you
understand some of these topics and
guide you in the specific case studies
dr prio paul is going to be a teaching
assistant that will help you
understand any kind of technical issues
that you will have throughout this
training and dr mohit mazum there who's
also a project mentor and an expert in
computational biology who will talk
about how sequence and structure poses
some interesting insights and future
directions for this kind of research
so
dr ragov i want to invite you next to
talk about
some of the examples that we discussed